we thought it might be happening and it
very clearly is happening Donald Trump
is scared to debate his fellow
Republican challengers in the 2024
Republican presidential primary he is
now using the cover of saying Fox News
is no longer a fair place for him to
have a debate as a part of the story he
is telling about why he will likely not
participate at least in the first
Republican primary debate scheduled for
August 23rd on Fox News let's be super
clear and just call this for what it is
Trump doesn't believe that debating will
be good for him and I have to tell you I
don't know that he is wrong he is
leading the Republican primary by quite
a bit and we're going to look at that
polling in a little bit
if the debates go well
he would still Simply Be leading the
Republican primary Maybe by a little
more but he's already winning by enough
to win the Republican primary on the
other hand if the debates don't go well
either because he stumbles or everybody
else gangs up on him make him look
stupid or they treat him unfairly
whatever
it can only hurt him and so Donald Trump
is aware of the fact that the debates
may be a risk to him given where the
polling is right now and now Donald
Trump is making this abundantly clear he
went on Newsmax yesterday he says he
doesn't know that he wants to do any
primary debates but specifically he says
Fox News Fox News is now hostile to him
and he just may not do it take a listen
then you have a heart still Network like
Fox like when I did the branch of the
the interview with Brett I thought it
was fine I thought it was okay but there
was nothing friendly about it you know
it was nasty and I thought I did a good
job I've been giving credit for doing a
good job but I've also people said why
would you do it because it was really
you know everything was like an
unfriendly it was always everything was
unfriendly no smiling no uh let's have
fun let's make America great again
everything was like a hit
so you know you have a hostile Network
and you have people that are obviously
the candidates are against you and uh
they therefore are being hustle and if
you're leading by the way isn't that
amazing he's like also the candidates
would be against me it's like well yeah
they're running against you of course
the candidates are going to be what he
wants the candidates to be for Trump on
the debate
Okay so
I mean listen reading between the lines
you don't have to read between the lines
very much Trump is saying I'm winning
now I don't really get the point it can
really only hurt me and it might
actually hurt me that is something that
actually might happen Trump then um
going on Truth social
and continuing the attacks end quote so
Fox News which is down 37 percent of the
capital R ratings doesn't cover my
getting the man of the decade award
because of my great trade policies in
Michigan or my keynote speech for Faith
and freedom in DC and then wants me to
show up and get them ratings for their
quote presidential debate where I'm
leading the field by 40 points all they
do is promote against all hope Ron de
sanctimonious and he's dropping Like a
Rock sorry Fox News life doesn't work
that way how bizarre has the American
political scene gotten Trump then
continuing to truth apoplectically quote
Fox News just covered from beginning to
the end the Rhonda sanctimonious very
boring con news conference at the
capital border but didn't cover one
minute of my two big speeches on
Saturday and Sunday night one for Faith
and freedom in DC the other about trade
in Michigan where I was presented with
the man of the decade award the
dissectus speech was just a rehash of
all the things I did to have the safest
and strongest Border in U.S history also
I'm up on him by 40 points and also up
big on Biden bottom line folks Trump is
afraid to debate
and it seems as though he is not going
to participate the first debate
scheduled for let's see what we have
here Politico has a guide to the first
presidential debate in the primary the
highly anticipated debate is going to
take place August 23rd at fizzerv
pfizerv Forum in Milwaukee where the RNC
is going to be held in 2024. Fox News
will host the event outline specifics on
Tuesday Brett Bayer and Martha McCallum
will be moderating
um and uh you know it's going to be on
Fox News and we'll have more information
as we get closer Trump indeed may not
debate and if that is the case I can
only imagine that his supporters will
say it is the only correct decision that
could possibly be made if you've been
thinking about getting a new mattress
Helix sleep is where I would start I've
been sleeping on Helix mattresses for
years now I recommend Helix to everyone
which is why I wanted them as a sponsor
if you don't want to take my word for it
Helix has been awarded number one
mattress by both GQ and Wired Magazine
and one of the things that makes Helix
unique is their sleep quiz I didn't
really know what kind of mattress would
be best for me but you do this short
sleep quiz you answer questions about
your body type and your preferences what
position you like to sleep in and Helix
will match you with the perfect mattress
for you so you know you're actually
getting some something tailored to your
needs instead of going in blind like
most people do I got my Helix mattress
designed to stay cool at night since I
hate getting hot while I sleep shipping
is always free you get a hundred nights
to decide whether you like it my
audience gets a huge 20 discount off of
all orders plus two free pillows go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is in the
description